[Music]  Abby Lee Miller may not be behind bars  much longer et has learned the former  dance mom stars official prison release  date has been moved up by nearly a month  according to the Federal Bureau of  Prisons Abby was set to leave prison on  June 21st but is set to be a free woman  on May 25th  hopefully the 51 year old was originally  given a February 20th release date after  being sentenced to one year and one day  in federal prison last July for  bankruptcy fraud but Abby's delayed  release had to do with a shift in the  Bureau of Prisons and budget  restrictions at halfway houses something  et is told was out of her control quote  it's nothing personal to Abby it's  happening to women in all different  federal prisons  [Music]